[Musik]
moderne
Metropolen und überforderte
Bauern wir sollen die Klimakrise lösen
das stickstoffproblem all das ist
ziemlich
frustrierend ein riesiger Seehafen und
erfolgreiche
Wirtschaft nicht nur die Politik auch
wir unternehmen müssen uns
große soziale Not die meisten
Niederländer sind nicht so sozial die
denken nur an sich selbst zerrissen das
Vertrauen in den
Staat wir wurden ignoriert uns wurde
Sand in die Augen
[Musik]
gestreut nordöstlichen Provinz Groningen
tiefe Risse überall an Ihrem
Haus die Regierung muss mein Haus nicht
reparieren aber es ist viel kaputt und
das liegt an den
Erdbeben immer wieder bebt die Erde hier
im Norden ausgelöst durch die
Gasförderung in Europas größtem Gasfeld
erst vor wenigen Wochen wurde die
Produktion endgültig
eingestellt viel zu spät meinen die
Menschen hier tausende Häuser sind
betroffen die Schäden gehen in die
Milliarden Anke deporte zeigt mir das
herrschaftliche Wohnzimmer der Grund
warum sie das Haus vor 16 Jahren gekauft
hat damals waren die Folgen der Erdbeben
noch nicht absehbar nun ist ihre Wut auf
die Regierung
groß es war reine Absicht wir wurden
ignoriert uns wurde Sand in die Augen
gestreut Entschädigung in Aussicht
gestellt und dann wieder gestoppt wir
hatten keine
perspektiveige Schäden hat sie
inzwischen beheben und die Mauern
stabilisieren lassen doch gerade erst
hat sie einen neuen Riss entdeckt in der
Außenwand es macht mich traurig weil die
bben weitergehen ich spüre das aber ich
muss irgendwie damit klarkommen ich
werde auch das wieder reparieren lassen
klar könnte ich umziehen aber ich will
doch hier wohnen bleiben das ist mein
Leben den Jahren hat sie insgesamt
100000€ für Reparaturen ausgegeben vom
Staat erst 40 000 € bekommen ob sie
weitere Gelder aus dem
Entschädigungsfond erhält sie weiß es
nicht
enttäuschte Erwartungen Misstrauen in
den Staat vor der Wahl treibt das viele
Niederländer um auch bei den Bauern im
Osten herrscht nur scheinbar idülle denn
es
brodelt auf den Kopf gestellte
niederländische Flaggen so zeigen die
Landwirte ihre Wut auf die
Regierung zu den wutbauern gehört auch
Kor pirik ich treffe ihn in der Provinz
ereisel hauptberuflich arbeitet der
58-Jährige beim nationalen Statistikamt
seine Leidenschaft gilt seinem
Hof mir gefällt es Bauer in der Natur zu
sein also Landwirtschaft mit
Landschaftspflege zu
verbinden die Freude der Bauern Natur
seit Jahren wird sie auf eine harte
Probe gestellt als Landwirt überleben
wird immer
schwieriger unser Einkommen gerätt immer
mehr unter Druck und gleichzeitig
erwartet die Gesellschaft immer mehr von
uns
Bau wir sollen die Klimakrise lösen das
stickstoffproblem und auch noch für mehr
atenvielfalt
Sorgen all das ist ziemlich frustrierend
dieser Frust treibt die Bauern seit
Jahren auf die Straße gegen Pläne der
Regierung den stickstoffausstoß der
Landwirtschaft zu halbieren Höfe mit zu
hohen Emissionen will die Regierung
aufkaufen oder notfallsgar
enteignen
kpirik hat sich entschieden er geht in
die Politik tritt bei der Wahl für die
bürgerbauernpartei an seine Mission die
Landwirtschaft gegen zu restriktive
Vorgaben
verteidigen wir haben in den letzten
Jahren gesehen für wie viel Unsicherheit
die Agrarpolitik der Regierung unter den
Bauern
sorgt sie wissen nicht wie sie
investieren sollen um überleben zu
können Wahlkampf im Nachbarort als
Kandidat der noch jungen
bürgerbauernpartei hat er gute Chancen
ins Parlament
einzuziehen als Abgeordneter will er das
Vertrauen der Landbevölkerung in die
Politik wier
stellen die Menschen sollen wissen dass
die Stimme der Bauern ins Parlament
einzieht wenn sie uns
wählen wir sind in den letzten Jahren
viel zu wenig gehört worden und dafür
will ich Sorgen deutlich machen dass es
wir Landwirte sind die für
Ernährungssicherheit
sorgen mit der bürgerbauernpartei
sympathisieren viele Menschen die sich
hier in der Provinz übersehen fühlen
gebeutelt von einer Sparpolitik die im
Osten die Infrastruktur stark ausgedünnt
hat Fabriken und Schulen
geschlossen Buslinien gestrichen früher
ist der Bus hier auch nur viermal am Tag
abgefahren jetzt wird er nur noch von
der nächst grrößeren Stadt das Gefühl
abgehängt zu sein vom modernen Leben in
den Ballungsräumen es ist hier zum
greifen habe das Gefühl dass sie für die
Provinz keine Verantwortung übernehmen
und verlangen dass wir uns
anpassen alles ist auf den Westen hin
ausgerichtet auf die Randstad und dann
erst kommt das platte
Land die Randstad der urbane Westen der
Niederlande moderne Architektur
Wohlstand und
Industrie die Firma bonedam ist
spezialisiert auf
Karusselltüren
niils Huber führt den Familienbetrieb
mehr als 1000 Mitarbeiter
Niederlassungen in aller
Welt R 90% unserer Produktion gehen ins
Ausland nur 10% also bleiben in den
Niederlanden und auch unsere
ausländischen Fachkräfte sind enorm
wichtig hier bei bohedam hoffen sie auf
eine weiterhin unternehmerfreundliche
Politik nach der Wahl Deregulierung und
niedrige gesteuern das wünscht sich
Niels Huber von einer neuen
Regierung ich denke wir könnten uns
gegenseitig mehr unterstützen nicht nur
die Politik muss sich verändern auch wir
unternehmen müssen uns stets neu
erfinden der Regierung helfen das Land
weiter erfolgreich zu
machen die niederländische Wirtschaft
gilt trotz aller Krisen als robust das
Land ist ein wichtiger
Verkehrsknotenpunkt für den Güterverkehr
der haen von Rotterdam der größte
Europas jedes Jahr werden hier fast 500
Millionen Tonnen an Gütern umgeschlagen
Kohle Erdöl
Chemikalien trotzdem in Rotterdam ist
die Arbeitslosigkeit höher als im Rest
der Niederlande das
Durchschnittseinkommen niedriger viele
Familien leben hier an der
Armutsgrenze die boterhamsters die
boteschmierer wollen die soziale Not
lindern die
lchboxen an Schulen Bob rechters hat sie
vor gut einem Jahr gegründet eigentlich
hat der Kunst studiert doch dann
verändert ein Zeitungsartikel sein Leben
RAM es wurde über einen Rotterdamer
Schüler berichtet der ist in der Schule
ohnmächtig geworden weil er das ganze
Wochenende über nichts gegessen hatte
für mich war das der Anstoß zu sagen wir
müssen sicherstellen dass an Schulen
Essen für bedürf schüere
1000 Lunchboxen jeden Tag zwei herzhafte
und zwei süße Sandwiches und immer auch
Obst das Supermärkte nicht mehr
verkaufen Bob rechters und seine Boe
Hamsters beliefern 20 Schulen im
Großraum Rotterdam sein Ziel heute eine
staatliche Grundschule im
brennpunktvertel charlos viele Kinder
kommen aus
Migrantenfamilien Nachfahren von
Einwanderern aus den ehemaligen Kolonien
bob rechters und sein Team finanzieren
sich über Spenden und Kostenbeiträge der
Schulen von der Politik erhofft er sich
mehr Aufmerksamkeit für die
Bedürftigen wir müssten mehr Links
wählen sozialer
wählen aber die meisten Niederländer
sind nicht so sozial eingestellt die
denken lieber an sich selbst das ist das
größte Problem
Tom Michels ist Sportlehrer und der
zuständige Ansprechpartner für die Bote
Hamsters seit kein Schüler mehr hungrig
im Unterricht sitzen muss haben sich
einige deutlich
verbessertal me enerie sie kommen auf
jeden Fall mit mehr Energie in die
Schule zum anderen haben Sie keine
größere lernhemmung mehr wir arbeiten
jetzt an den Ergebnissen einer
wissenschaftlichen Studie wir wollen
herausfinden welche Auswirkungen eine
gesündere Ernährung wirklich hat die
Studie läuft aber
noch die leeren lchboxen werden gespült
und wieder verwendet in Zukunft will Bob
auch noch warme Mahlzeiten liefern
kleine Schritte die großen müsse die
Gesellschaft machen findet
er wir haben doch genug um zu teilen und
in den Niederlanden ist Platz für alle
wenn wir als reiches Land dafür sorgen
dass niemand mehr auf Hilfe angewiesen
ist dann sparen wir am Ende sogar eine
Menge Steuergeld
davon würden wir alle
profitieren aber dieser Schalter muss
erstmal umgelegt
werden die Vision von einer gerechten
Zukunft in den Niederlanden scheinen
viele Menschen davon zu träumen ich
fahre zurück in den Osten in die Provinz
relderland hier ist der Zweitligist
derfsra zu Hause vor dem Spiel trifft
sich der Stammtisch des Fanclubs zum
fachsimpel Sitz des Clubs und stolz auf
seinen
Verein alle Fans können sich richten zu
uns wenn es ein Problem gibt oder wenn
die froh sind auch wir sind für alle
Fans da und helfen wenn nötig und
versuchen auch um die die verschiedene
Gruppen Fangruppen zusammen zu bringen
und zusammen zu halten wir einig nach
Auen sind
als wurden sie einst von den Anhängern
der großstadtclubs verspottet längst
nennen sie sich selber so selbstbewusst
gegenüber dem Westen der vom Staat
bevorzugt wird davon ist Hans busberg
überzeugt es fließt mehr Geld in die
Randstad als hierher warum haben wir
hier weniger Kultur hier wohnen auch
Menschen aber hier fahren immer weniger
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel das sind
Dinge die mich stören und die sich
ändern
sollten Heimspiel gegen die Mannschaft
von nackbreda aus dem Südwesten der
Niederlande vor 11000
Zuschauern im Stadion feiern sie ihre
Mannschaft das
Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl der Region
schwingt immer
mit hier kennt man sich noch man grüßt
sich wir kümmern uns umeinander bei
Krankheit und Gesundheit so ist das hier
und deshalb will ich nicht
weg dass man einander verbunden ist man
kennt sich kann sich aufeinander
verlassen ich glaube das macht unsere
Nachbarschaft
aus für die Fans von dersra wird es ein
guter Abend mit 1:0 gewinnen die
superbauern gegen den Rivalen aus Breder
das FIFA Berg Stadion bebt und Hans
busberg bringt die Mentalität der Region
ja vielleicht des ganzen Landes auf den
Punkt wenn man was erreichen will muss
man kämpfen und beweisen dass man da ist
lass das Sehen Ruf
superburen
[Gelächter]
immer nach dem Spiel ist vor der Wahl
von der sich jeder etwas anderes erhofft
der Osten sucht den Anschluss an die
moderne der Westen Lösungen für seine
sozialen Probleme der Norden hofft auf
Gerechtigkeit die Niederlande vor der
Wahl
[Musik]